Now, that we've talked about what an equation really is and what types of
equations there are, let's actually build some up. To do that, we're going to
keep helping Grant deal with his manufacturing process. Since Grant's Gleaming
Glasses has started manufacturing now, they actually have to pay for things,
namely, the materials they use to make glasses wipers and nozzles. To buy just
the material that he needed to make the wipers that were produced in the first 4
days, Grant spent $598. He's thinking that next week, he'll need to spend around
$750 to start the nozzle manufacturing process. We know from that chart we made
earlier, that he was able to make 92 glasses wipers in the first 4 days. Oh, and
he also told me that he took his friends out to lunch and he spent 54 more
dollars on that. To plan for the future, Grant is getting a little bit worried.
There are a lot of different numbers he needs to keep track of. He wants to know
how much he spends on the materials to make just one set of wiper blades, but he
needs our help to sift through all these numbers.